we know that everything in the universe
is composed of atoms but not all atoms
are the same
there are many different types of atoms
called elements each with a unique set
of physical and chemical properties
many elements are probably familiar to
you oxygen and carbon for example are
elements and so is gold
others may be less familiar such as
bismuth Xenon and osmium
a particular element is identified by
the number of protons and its atoms and
the number of protons in the nucleus of
an atom is its atomic number represented
by the symbol Z
for example helium has an atomic number
of two
that means that every helium atom has
two protons
and here's another example iron
its atomic number is 26 so every iron
atom has 26 protons
an element's atomic number can also tell
us the number of electrons in a neutral
atom of an element remember equal and
opposite charges cancel each other out
so to be neutral an atom must have an
equal number of protons which have a
charge of one plus and electrons which
have a charge of one minus this means
that our helium atom must have two
electrons and our iron atom must have 26
electrons
all of the known elements are organized
according to their atomic numbers in the
periodic table the periodic table lists
the elements in order of increasing
atomic number as you go from left to
right and from top to bottom the
elements are further organized into
columns based on their properties
elements in the same column tend to have
similar physical and chemical properties
every element is represented by a
chemical symbol a unique one or two
letter abbreviation that appears below
the element's atomic number on the
periodic table
many chemical symbols are based on the
English name for an element for example
the symbol for hydrogen is H and the
symbol for aluminum is Al
but some chemical symbols are based on
the Latin name for the element for
example the symbol for lead is PB which
actually comes from its Latin name
plumbum
notice that whenever the chemical symbol
for an element has two letters the
second letter is written in lower case
all of this information is contained
inside of each element's box on the
periodic table for example here's the
box for the element nitrogen at the top
of the box is nitrogen's atomic number
which is seven remember that this is
equal to the number of protons in each
atom of nitrogen as well as the number
of electrons
below that is nitrogen's chemical symbol
n followed by its name often you'll also
see another number listed at the bottom
of an element's box which has to do with
atomic mass we'll cover details about
this in another video
what's neat about having all of this
information in one place is that if we
know one detail about an element either
its atomic number chemical symbol or
name we can often use the periodic table
to find out the other details
let's take a look at a few examples
say we have the element phosphorus what
is its atomic number and chemical symbol
looking through the periodic table we
can find phosphorus and see that its
atomic number is 15 and its chemical
symbol is p
let's do another example say we know the
chemical symbol HG what is this
element's name and how many protons does
it have
here is the symbol HG on the periodic
table its name is Mercury and its atomic
number is 80. so it has 80 protons
let's review the universe is made up of
different types of atoms called elements
and these elements are organized by
atomic number in the periodic table
so the next time that you stare up at
the Starry Sky you know that everything
out there is made up of elements